happened to dante was murdered
when i got that call about dante i
couldn't believe it
i fell to the ground in pain that no one
should have to go through
it was the hardest time of our life
we lost a very special person so i write
this letter to you dante demetrious
right
we miss you more than ever our lives
aren't normal anymore i think about you
every day i lost not only my best friend
but my baby brother
i would remember when we would play
games when we were young and you would
get mad if you lost and you would start
crying and turn red in the face because
you didn't win
i remember when me you dad and everybody
used to go fishing and we would argue
over who was going to catch the biggest
fish everything was a competition
between us boys
now we won't be able to compete with
each other anymore i won't be able to
see you get old i won't be able to hear
your voice change
i won't be able to tell you i love you
one last time
i think about this stuff every day
you were stripped away from us this has
been the longest most alone miserable
times of our life
we never felt the pain like this we lost
a very important piece to our family
i promise i will never give up fighting
for you because that's what big brothers
do
so i wrote this little
poem i have
your memories my keepsake
will never be a part god has you in this
keeping but we'll have you in our heart
you never said i'm leaving you never
said a goodbye you were gone before we
knew it and only god knows why
there has been a million times that we
needed you and a million times we cried
if our love could have saved you
you never would have died in life i love
you dearly
and death i love you still
in our hearts you hold a place
that no one could ever feel
it broke our heart to lose you but you
didn't go alone for part of us was with
you when god called you home
i promise
to my family that i would take care
of everybody including our siblings
dallas destiny diamond monica marcus and
of course your baby dante jr
i cannot express how painful it was for
our family to see the defendant smiling
in her mug shot immediately after being
convicted of killing my brother
i respectfully ask the court to give a
strong sentence that accounts for the
severe
pain and loss that our family has
experienced thank you so much for giving
me this opportunity rest in peace dante
right
thank you
diamond right
please come forward
and miss wright will you please spell
state and spell your name
uh diamond right d-i-a-m-o-n-d
ghg
thank you
um hi my name is diamond wright i am
dante wright's second youngest sister
i never thought in a lifetime that i'd
be standing here doing this i never
thought that my brother
would be killed
sorry
would be killed by the same people we're
supposed to feel protected by
i know that
the charge is manslaughtered but i
believe this should be called murder
ever since my brother was killed my
heart's been shattered and the only
thing that's putting it back together is
the memories we shared
i feel like i've been living in a
complete nightmare it got so bad to the
point i couldn't sleep i stopped eating
and even got depressed
the death of a loved one is not only an
emotional pain but also a physical pain
the defendant should be prosecuted and
sentenced to the highest extent
you can't tell me this was an accident
it's in plain sight she has been a
police officer on longer than my brother
has been alive
how come i have to go see my brother in
a metal container just to talk to him
how come i have to pray that my brother
hears me cry out to him
how come my family has to groan and moan
about the loss of a loved one just
because the defendant's actions were
reckless
dante was my brother my blood someone
who was supposed to grow old with me how
is it that i'm going to see the age of
21 and he didn't
he didn't get to experience the life he
was supposed to
um
watch his kids grow
and watch his kid's appearance grow old
not many of you know dante and i
couldn't care less on what anyone anyone
else thinks of him
you don't know him he could light up a
whole stadium with his smile and laugh
i miss him stealing food with my mom is
cooking at family functions
i miss when he would play fight with me
and my little sister
i miss him
and i would trade anyone in this room to
get him back
everyone just sees this as another black
man getting killed by the police but not
us
this one hit home this this time it was
one of us
[Music]
every day i would walk around and it
feels like i'm really not here it feels
like i'm just an empty body taking up
space
you took my other half
i remember when dante was alive and the
george floyd killing was being discussed
a lot
and me my mom and dante were having a
talk saying just maybe we have enough
whiteness for us not to be a threat to
the police we were wrong
we have repeatedly seen that one hint of
black in our skin makes us a target
this is sickening i miss you dante i
miss your smile your laugh the way
towards your hair when you were nervous
or thinking about something
i miss what he used to come upstairs
just to talk stuff and then run back
down
you were a great big brother you taught
us this is how to be tough how to listen
and how to calm down when we were upset
you really did your big brother roll
well
can i love you dante and you'll always
be in my heart
until we meet again
thank you
[Music]
miss china walker whitaker
now if we could just have a moment sure
[Music]
hmm
okay miss whitaker will you please state
your full name and spell it
chyna marie whitaker um c h y n a
marie m a r i e whitaker w h i t a k
e r
can i start
okay
my name is chyna whitaker
i am the mother of dante's only child
dante wright junior
dante was born 25 weeks premature
and had to stay in the nicu for a little
over two months
during that time
his father and i were very concerned
about him
making a full recovery
however by the grace of god he is still
here today
he is now two years old
and since april 11 2021
fatherless
kim potter took my son's best friend
away from him
and things haven't been the same since
i am now a single mother
not by choice by force
my son hasn't seen his dad in almost a
year
and i know he doesn't understand what's
going on but he senses his dad being
gone
he was used to spending time with his
father
oftentimes he would stay the night with
his dad
and have bonding time
that gave me a chance to have a break
when i need it
now i can't even pick up the phone to
call him
due to this situation
my son is a lot more scattered
and angry
he acts up a lot more
i now have him in school
to learn and socialize with other
children
to cope
during this difficult time in our lives
my child will no longer have the
opportunity
to spend birthdays or holidays with his
dad
dante will never get to see his son's
first day of preschool
high school
or college
they didn't even get the chance to play
ball
or sports together
this is not the way it should be
every time i look at my son i'm reminded
of what was taken away from him
i show my son pictures
and videos of his dad and his face
lights up with the biggest smile and he
says that uh
it hurts me because
i know if he had the chance to see his
dad again
it will fill the hole in his heart that
is now there
i can't take the place of his father
neither can any other man
all i can do is hope and pray things get
better for us
i now suffer from severe
ptsd
whenever i'm pulled over i have extreme
anxiety
afraid of making a mistake and something
ended up going wrong
i can't watch any movies or videos that
have to do with police brutality
because it reminds me it does hit me and
killed
i got my son a poster of his dad that i
keep in his bedroom
many times i just find him staring at it
my son shouldn't have to wear a resting
piece shirt of his dad
police are supposed to protect and serve
the community
how will my son learn to trust
police after what happens to his dad
i don't want my son to grow up afraid
of the police or hating them
nevertheless
it's only fair that kim potter be
sentenced to the maximum amount of time
for executing my son
dante junior's father
thank you very much
all right uh here are the defense
arguments regarding sentencing mr inge
okay please support
him
this is beyond tragic
for everybody involved
and we hear clearly the
statements of the family
[Music]
we recognize them
there's no
disrespect intended to the booking
photograph at shakopee
this
potter indicates they asked her to smile
she smiled
but it was not
meant to be disrespectful it was in
response to the prison's request
[Music]
there are two questions for the court
today um
the first is whether to
dispositionally depart and the second is
to durationally part to depart if you're
unwilling to disposition your depart so
that the key question is the first one
and that is a question of whether or not
in law and in fact
officer potter is particularly amenable
on probation and to answer that question
we rely on
the probation office to
initially evaluate the claim
[Music]
i often think sometimes probation
officers are not given enough credit
for the work they do
um because there's always disputes that
sentencing and
they can please no one really
but in this case the report is
exceptional
it's well done it's well written
it's fair
it says all the bad facts for the
defense and all the good facts
for us as well
it has a sense of balance to it
and the report does suggest to you that
oscar potter is a man of all the
probation it's it's a
recommendation that carries heavy weight
because the probation office is what you
rely on to make decisions
they do the investigation they actually
talk
to the defendant
and the family
and make a decision or recommendation as
to probation and whether she's amenable
and she is
according to that report
um
so the first hurdle for
any
defendant asking for amenability
findings is to
get past the probation report we've done
that
and that report alone would provide you
with authority
and reasonable reliance to impose a
probationary sentence
this um
this was an unintentional crime it was
an accident it was a mistake
um
and
the the claim and the state's brief as
well the the guidelines suggest 86
months therefore we should follow them
but then if we dig deeper
we realize that the guidelines aren't
always followed and for 60
of the women
in minnesota
who face a presumptive commit
they are given
probationary dispositions
so on the one hand we can say well the
guidelines are 86 months on the other
hand we should also say they aren't
always followed in 60 percent of the
time for females and for males
they aren't followed in 30 35 percent in
in our sister
jurisdiction
in ramsey county they're not follow 50
according to the most recent evaluation
booklet of the sentencing guidelines
commission
and the reason they're not followed is
that they're too high
for many defendants especially for the
first time defendants
there's a recognition in the court
system
that individuals who face the court the
first time
need not go to prison
in order to
effectuate adjust result
so the departure rate is really high and
the question for the court is not only
whether she's amenable to probation but
whether she should fall into the 60
range
i got to get my water here for seconds
the factors in trog are clearly found
here in a state versus trogg it was a
um
huge opinion when it came out in 1982
we all
for those of us around in 1982 was it
was an astounding opinion because it
it provided the probationary option uh
under the new guidelines and you know
all the factors that are listed in that
case she meets
there's no record
she's got a 26-year work history she has
expressed contrition and remorse which
i'll talk about a little bit later in
terms of the quality of it
she bears no risk of recidivism she
can't be a police officer in the future
there's no danger to the public
she'll never own a gun again obviously
and that she has enormous community
support which i'll talk about in a
second as well so that the factors are
all there that you've had the report
that says probation is available and
then we have the trog factors
um
[Music]
which
resonate here
and i often think of i i you know i know
we
you know i often think of judge amdahl
um what he might do here
you know
i mean he gave a break to mr truck
affirmed that sentence
i dare say it's hard to know what
anyone do but
i dare say he might find that
the factors here persuasive for
oscar potter in his memory
you know what i think
um the court misses in all these
cases there's an interaction with the
family we
we um we had a chance to be in this room
next door
and
there's a jury room attached to it and
so we spent a month with
um kim's family
and
every day there was a new set that came
in to be with her you know the
husband who's here their
sisters are here and his sister-in-law
but then there were nephews and friends
of the family and former police officers
and it was
different every day
and they sat in the jury room and earl
and
me and i sat in the courtroom and we
gave them their time
i wish you could have seen it
um
you know i think they were all there to
be with her
to pay their respects to her for
everything that she had done for them
and i wish you could see
the tremendous amount of
love they had for her
and non-gentleman
non-judgmental empathy they had for her
in that room
and we all found it remarkable
and we all found that we should leave
them alone
and even during the jury deliberation
she was there with her two sons and her
husband and often in her
husband's arms
crying
and
the boys were with her and it was
moving i'll say that
and i think they were all there all the
family members and the friends because
she has lived
um a virtuous life and they are trying
to pay her back i um
you know i think of when i think of kim
i think of the someone who's
lived out all the virtues that we could
imagine she's a catholic
i've talked to her about the catholic
virtues
they're well known to catholics but
perhaps not the courts the catholic
virtues are prudence
justice temperance courage fortitude
faith
hope
charity
and the biggest virtue of olives of
course is kindness
and she has lived those out
and we want to be secular because we are
a secular court we could refer to
aristotle's virtues
and he gave the advice that that if we
want to live a virtuous life we practice
small acts of virtue of course and
aristotle's virtues are
courage temperance liberality patience
truthfulness
friendliness fortitude
and she's done all of that too
so you have to balance this for one
five second mistake against all of this
i
and if the virtues get too complex i
often think of
um
a famous line from sao bello's
perhaps his greatest book
where he talks about
this he says i have a feeling about the
axial lines of life
with respect to which you must be
straight
and later in the paragraph
he says when the striving stops they are
as a gift
so we can forget about the catholic
virtues or aristotle's virtues and just
say
have you lived a straight line
have you tried to live a straight line
axial or otherwise
because she's lived a straight line she
has enormous community support
and had she not lived a straight line
she wouldn't be here with all these
people that i'm going to talk about
now the state contends in
their memorandum that the claim of
remorse and amenability to probation is
quote
not particularly compelling
we take issue with that
the public would disagree
since she's been in prison
she has received three boxes
of cards
dear kim how are you
here can we care about you
and i want those to know who wrote these
cards this is just one of three by the
way
thousands of cards
that she intends to answer each one so
for those of you who are watching
she will answer you
because she always has
but let me give you and i didn't submit
all these to the court it did
i thought i would read a couple just to
give you a sample
and they're all very short and heartfelt
this one's from
an officer up in the northern part of
minnesota
[Music]
my dear kim she writes
my name is i work there i
i want you to know that i can
that even though we've never met
my heart is completely broken for you
and i'm devastated by your situation
i've also been in law enforcement for a
long time
i have two sons and i'm just destroyed
on your behalf
what happened to you could have happened
to any of us
as a law enforcement community across
the country we're reeling
from the justice from the shock of this
case
this
deputy's hope is that
you
and your family will be protected from
feelings of despair
and that you may be physically safe
she concluded by saying i've never been
so moved by a situation like this i want
you to know
in your heart and remember every day
that you are not alone
here's one from chaska they're all small
cards
people took the time to write her this
is unheard of for a defendant
i dare say no one in this room has ever
seen anything like this
dear kim
i hope this message finds you well
heart shape
i do not have the right words but please
know that i support you
i support blue
you have an amazing community behind you
please know that you're not alone
you make the world a better place
be good to yourself and kind
to your heart with love from chaska
these cards came from all over the
country and all over the world actually
we've gotten caught up in europe
one final one then i'll move on
this one's
handwritten
brooklyn park
dear ms potter
my name is
my heartaches for your situation i want
you to know you're in my prayers
constantly
my husband is a retired state trooper
and knows the agony
of split-second decisions
if okay with you
i'd like to write you regularly
sincerely
judy
and roughly a third
of these letters want to have
continued communications with her
[Music]
and then despite
the community support and the remorse
that she's going to
articulate for you again today after i'm
done
um
the state's claim is that she just
hasn't done enough or shown enough
you know
we're all unique
individuals and what the state may find
to be a level of remorse that they'd
like to see may not be
what someone feels in their heart
themselves
her feelings are her feelings
and i get the sense that we're somehow
the state is somehow asking to
subjectively evaluate her level of
remorse
and make a standard
of subjectivity that they want
um but the core has never been never
been required to parse out that sort of
level you're just supposed to look at
the trog factors does she express
remorse or doesn't she you can't
engage in psychoanalysis here
that's not the holding of trog
she was remorseful the moment the gun
was fired she went into trauma
rosters at the scene then
called in
the tragedy and the police responded
immediately
the state contends that she has no
quote-unquote moral anguish
but the record is replete that she does
i mean she testifies she does that the
videos of
of kim crying on the ground are
replete with more language
i mean
we just can't have a kafka yes
standard of what
remorse is and then have the state say
well you haven't
met our standard
and we ask well what is the standard and
then
we just haven't seen enough remorse so
we don't know what the standard is and
so we never can meet what their standard
is
but that's not how law works it's never
worked that way
so the question again is whether she's
amenable
and she included in the 60 percent
the state seems to agree that she is
at page six of their memo
they set out the various
conditions that would satisfy them
so it's a hedging memo
it's the kind of memo that concedes that
the defense has a claim for amenability
and the conditions that they want we
accept
i mean
they want a meeting with the family
and we accept that we would do that in
the adversarial system that's impossible
but now it is and we would welcome that
with court supervision somehow
they want
ms potter to give
speeches and presentations about weapons
confusion we will do that
she's willing to go across the state and
talk about that
to the extent that she can discuss the
confusion and design
features of a taser and how
inappropriate they may be we'll be happy
to do that
um
it was something that was not possible
before trial
but it's possible now
the other factors for probation that go
beyond trog
are
vulnerability to the prison setting
she is
in an isolated setting right now in
shakopee
they have her isolated because they
don't want her in the regular population
as a police officer she would be
vulnerable to assault
the people in
prison um in order to get prison can be
quite violent those 40 of the women
so they've isolated it and the related
ground for
amendability to probation or for
probationary disposition is that
there is a there has been a diminution
of her mental health well in isolation
and i know the court's intent was never
to place her in isolation in prison but
the fact of the matter is that in my
discussions with the prison officials
they have decided that she should see no
one
so all she does is spend her days
getting checked 30 every 30 minutes by a
guard making isolated phone calls
and staying in her cell
and as a result
she like many people who are in
isolation suffer
from
a decline
of mental and physical health and we
know from statistics and the analysis of
social science that
isolation
in prison
is harmful
and so while the court
never
dreamed that perhaps that she would be
in such an
isolated setting it is harming her
so we have on the one hand punishment
but on the other hand if you send her to
prison you will harm her
we are not in the business of harming
defendants
if there's any question about it we
submitted her therapist letter to you in
confidence confirming that such
isolation is harmful
given her
fragile states
and her diagnosis
the greatest sin of all
in the church in the secular world is a
failure of generosity
and i submit to you that
kim never committed that sin
willingly or intentionally
she in her world
met the obligation to do good
and she did
and because she did good we ought not be
cheap about her life either because it's
been a generous life
to everybody she's met
you know hennepin county is a wonderful
district because it's innovative
um this is the busiest district in the
state but you know the
the bench
is famous for
um
providing programs to first-time
offenders to keep them out of jail
the drug court was tremendously
innovative
remand was innovative the property
courts
there's a veterans court
and all these
ideas were new once they started
and they were tremendous because they
kept people out of prison
and engaged engaged in sort of a
forgiveness if they would do certain
things and you know in drug court for
example many people were looking at
presumptive commits and never went
they got help they got treatment
and they were part of the 30 of men who
don't go
and we're famous for this
we're
this is a district with a big heart
and the other districts across the state
have
adapted and adopted what we've done here
in hennepin
county we should be
thinking along the same lines for her
i've got a
i've got a couple letters and then i'll
reach the durational departure and then
we'll hear from him
um
i've
submitted all these to the court i know
you've read them this is just
profound
this too is unheard of
i must tell you i edited out
at least 25 to 50 but it didn't sound
they were redundant or just
not quite right to send some of them
questions what happened here
which is okay to voice but this is
tremendous
the last part just came in
to brooklyn center for her
and i had no difficulty requesting
people to write letters they just kept
coming and coming i have a stack in my
office which came in too late
but i have
you know i've read them all there's one
that's
a couple that i'd like to quote to you
because they
um
tell us who she is
and why you should give her a break here
the first one is from an emt
[Music]
this was written to me and i've sent it
to you
i want to quote parts of it
i hope i can get through it frankly
although i only knew officer potter
professionally throughout my 25
paramedic career i
had never witnessed officer potter
mistreats disrespect nor use any force
on any individual
oster potter had an amazing way of
connecting with everybody
she was nothing but professional helpful
caring to the other first responders and
individuals in crisis involved in a
9-1-1 call
her aura was infectious
and quickly gained respect on an
ecologist simply by walking into the
scene
you see officer potter never introduced
herself in any other way than kim
to the families and individuals that
requested 9-1-1 assistance
all the letters said the same thing
but this one was unique
the emt recounts that in 2009
one of her colleagues was killed
um
she was at the scene with him as he died
i remember seeing the look on his face
after he's lying there on the floor
it was like i'd never seen before i
couldn't remember some events after this
and so happened that
officer potter was at the honor guard
at the funeral
once officer kept checking on me as well
as my other colleagues making sure we
were all taken care of
she made a huge impact on all of us
during this devastating time
the mt goes on to state that she was
suffering from ptsd
which may have occurred here too
denied her colleague's death
she goes on to say i thought i was
hiding my symptoms pretty well until one
day i went on medical call in brooklyn
center with officer potter we were
we ended up not transporting the
individual in an ambulance
we were walking out together
after the call officer potter once again
asked me how i was doing
i always responded fine thanks while
sitting
inside of the back of the ambulance on
the bench seat with the back doors of
the ambulance open oscar potter jumped
in
in the back of the ambulance and shut
the doors
so just the two of us were there inside
officer potter put her right hand on my
right shoulder
and looked me straight in the eye
i'll never forget what she then said
i've been noticing
you have not been yourself for some time
now
what can i do to help
of course i tried not to show her that i
was hurting oster potter sat down
on the stretcher right in front of me
and grabbed my hand
she told me it's okay to feel pain
i immediately began to tear up and oscar
potter stayed with me and called me
please keep in mind i only knew officer
potter professionally during my whole
career
she did not have to take this time
nor did she owe me anything
it was just her personality and
character
i can honestly say she genuinely
cares for everyone she meets
monster potter helped me out of a
dark place
where i had no idea
about the true meaning of ptsd
without this interaction with oscar
potter i can say i don't know how long
it would have taken me to get help
and realize how much
with all my ptsd
from the line of duty
and death had taken on me
i had no respect for oscar potter that
day
i truly learned just how much of an
impact your kindness meant
every time i would run into or on a
medical call
after this day we would check in on each
other and offer a smile
with her help i was able to retire from
law enforcement
being proud of the people i served
she concludes by saying emt does she is
an incredible officer as well as person
this would
the world would be an amazing place if
everyone
would strive to be even half the person
she is
thank you for your time with the civil
rights
so she is amenable
she's particularly amenable given her
life
in a sentence which would stay the
prison sentence
would be justin right here
and i only approached the durational
departure issue as a as a secondary
argument
i offer no disrespect
to mr redness family but there is a
departure ground and i would like to
articulate it to you
it's all over the letters under section
2d
0.203 a1
if the victim is an aggressor
that is considered a mitigating fact
a single mitigating fact is sufficient
under the law that's state versus
solberg
82 northwest 2nd 6 18 6
6 14 6 18 minnesota 216.
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with raising this
as a factor this is an adversarial
system
[Music]
for duty bound to advocate for the least
amount of time
and again i offer no disrespect here
but we're lawyers for her
um
and if the victim was aggressive
at his mitigating ground i would like i
request the court if
to make findings
for for the community
particularly for the law enforcement
community that there was aggression on
on behalf of on on the part of mr wright
you know driving that license car
without insurance perhaps not there was
marijuana in the car
past instance of flights
um he was arguably intoxicated with
marijuana
which driving a car while intoxicated is
a violent act it can be
um i would like the court to acknowledge
that warrants of the court do matter and
should be honored
this was a warrant for his arrest
i'd like the court to acknowledge that
uh running away from the police officers
three three of them isn't is a is a
violent act it's an aggressive act
[Music]
and that in this case it has no
potential harming the officers and it
did according to the testimony
the state on the other hand says this
quotes dante wright was not an aggressor
against defendant dante wright made no
aggressive or violent movements toward
defender potter or the other officers
dante wright simply
pulled away from oscar lucky in an
attempt to drive off
we beg to differ
the testimony of officer lucky and
sergeant johnson is that there was this
was a dangerous situation
sergeant johnson was reaching in to
prevent him from driving away and could
have been hurt
he said so
this was an aggressive act
i don't know how it couldn't be
aggressive
um there is no requirement that
kim potter be a victim of the aggression
herself
the law says that she can defend
other officers on the scene and so
statue 609066 so
um you know she can do that the whole
idea of this victim of aggressor
mitigation is whereas here there's a
self-defense claim that's defeated it's
not perfect
the jury rejected it but nonetheless the
facts show that the victim mr wright was
in the aggressor and so when that
happens and it happens here
you have a durational departure ground
the state would also say
don quotes it's repeated again their
claim is that dante wright was quotes
not combative with the officer he made
no threats to the officer he did not
aggress act aggressively towards the
officer
that's at page 11. that's that's
inconsistent with the record
we take issue with that
[Music]
her intended response here
to the aggression
was
to use the taser
clearly that's what the facts show
and therefore her conduct was rooted in
an innocent mistake
believing that she was using a taser and
had a gun
and that makes
the case significantly less serious than
the typical manual slaughter case
because it was rooted in a mistake
rooted in innocence
at the moment in response to a violent
act that makes it different
here and so you have durational
departure of the grounds
and the state seems to agree
that
departure grounds do exist because
they're
they're they're falling away from the
blakely claim no longer are they asking
for 10 to 20 years or whatever they were
asking for
um
and the blakely claim was critical at
trial because they got all this evidence
in of
dante wright's
[Music]
scene of death
on the grounds as you recall they know
it's blakely we got to get it in but
they've abandoned that
um
and i would suggest to you that the case
was overcharged
they should never charge first degree
manslaughter for a first time a
defendant
you should never ask for 86 months for
someone like her
i have a couple more letters tonight
this one is from
the former chief of police of brooklyn
center
this came in late but i forwarded it to
you i hope you got a chance to read it
it's um
[Music]
he recounts that in july of 2014 i
responded with several officers to a
report of a toddler who had been struck
by a vehicle what happened here is that
the
child had been run over by his father
ben died
um everybody at the scene was having
a difficult time with the call he says
we forget how much trauma police
experience on a daily basis frankly
i took this call very hard says the
former chief as i had just welcomed my
second child to this world a few weeks
earlier her name was the same name as a
little girl
who died in the accident
my other child was a 14 month old girl
i read this letter because the following
happened
quotes kim came to my office a few days
after this tragedy she closed
the door sat down and placed her feet on
my desk
something i
normally assume would be followed with a
resignation letter
she asked me how i was doing
she was talking to me person to person
not as a co-worker manager
in just a few minutes she had my trust
to share the challenges i was having
with the accident call
i felt like a 10 ton weight was lifted
from my shoulders and it was life
changing
i was seriously considering leaving law
enforcement a year early
as a result of this call and she helped
me move past my doubts
kimberly has helped many other officers
first responders and officers
and if others benefit just benefit just
by a fraction of how i did
i know it made a notable impact on their
lives
in closing i know there are hundreds
of examples of kimberly's selfless acts
to help others
she didn't do it for money as none of
these examples involve pay
she didn't do it for promotion
has nothing here as a rank
she did it because she truly cares about
helping others
you know he didn't have to write that
i returned to family for her
you know her son is written to you as
well
again i wish you could have seen this in
the room with the two boys
young men
samuel potter says my mom is my rock
she is the reason i am where i am today
she's the reason i'm a man i am today
without her i don't know where i would
be
she raised my brother and me to live by
the golden rule
to treat people how we want to be
treated
i feel i do this to the best of my
ability
and we can't ask any more of a young man
than that
can we
last uh excerpt i'd like to read then i
will conclude it comes from her mother
i think for those who have lost our
mothers um
this will
even resonate further
because once you once you've lost your
mother
there's an incredible vacuum in your
life
you may recall that her mother came to
the
trial a couple times and sat
in the corner and watched her daughter
testifying
she says
i am almost 82 years old
and i need quite a lot of help now
kim is such a help to me
she's the one who cleans my apartment
changes my sheets
and makes sure i have what i need
she helps me go places because i can no
longer drive long distances or drive
easily in the dark
she helps me with my banking
and my bills so i don't pay anything
late
these things have gotten a lot harder
for me as i've gotten older
and kim keeps me on track
tripping axial line there too
kim is my daughter but she's also my
friend
she's the youngest of our four children
by several years
when the older ones went away to college
kimberly was the one who left one left
at home she spent she and i spent a lot
of time together
and we were very close i confide in her
she's always able to understand me and
help me when i have a question
or when i'm worried about something
[Music]
then she goes on to say this
she's a good person
and it makes me sad that people are
talking so terribly about her
make all kinds of conclusions about her
because she chose her career to be a
police officer
they just assume things and they don't
even take the time to try to get to know
her before they make all kinds of
judgments and awful statements about her
we taught her to treat others as she
would want to be treated
i feel sad that other people in our city
don't do the same why do we just keep
letting people do this
kimberly was a good officer but the job
is a stressful one i don't know how she
did it
i wouldn't have wanted to but we need
police officers to protect us i'm glad
someone wants to do it
if we send good police officers to jail
when they make mistakes we won't have
anyone
who wants to be one
which is a reframe of many letters
she concludes
her mother does i love my daughter
i'm proud of her
i think that you know in your heart that
it was a horrible
accident please be lenient and give her
probation so she can come home and help
maybe
you know this is this is a very unique
defendant here given her age and career
and it's
you know i i would
urge to the court to approach it this
way maybe it's time we should help her
too
you know we're we're helping all sorts
of defendants who come through hennepin
county and
she should be helped
this is
something that perhaps she's never going
to get over i don't think she's ever
going to get over it frankly even the
report that you've read
um
and then it's time to reach out to
someone like her and say okay
what can we do for you
uh a lower sentence within our thinking
and the way of thinking reflect the
rules or the roles of mercy and
forgiveness which are both essential i
you know what remains of her life is
that she's been a good daughter and a
good sister
she's a loving mother two wonderful boys
young men
she's been a wonderful companion to her
husband jeff
who completely adores her and rightly so
um
[Music]
she loved her community
and she absolutely loved being a police
officer
and
these are the relationships that
mark a life
and form
the units of a life
and made these units of her life be the
ultimate calculation for mitigation here
thank you
all right um we're gonna take a
15-minute break and
then um
i'll allow uh miss potter if she wishes
to to address the court okay
so 15 minutes
oh you figured it out okay
[Music]
okay miss potter would you like to
address the court
please go to the podium and you may
remove your mask
thank you
dante right
i am so sorry that i brought the death
of your father okay miss potter
okay my court reporter can't hear you
um so
[Music]
thank you
to the family of dante right
i am so sorry
that i brought the death of your son
father brother
uncle grandson
nephew and the rest of your family
to your home
okay i understand the mother's love
and i am sorry i broke your heart
my heart is broken from all of you
earlier when you said that i didn't look
at you
during the trial
i don't believe i had a right to
i didn't even have a right to be in the
same room with you
i am so sorry
that i hurt you so badly
my heart
is broken and devastated for all of you
i pray for dante
and all of you many
many times a day
is not more than one thought away from
my heart and i have no right for that
for him to be in my heart
i do pray that one day you can find
forgiveness only because hatred is so
destructive to all of us
and that i pray
peace will always be with you and your
family
again i am so sorry
and to the community of brooklyn center
i do owe you an apology too
i loved working for you
and i am sorry what has happened to our
community
since the death of dante
and the men and women who work for you
still
are good honorable people
and will work hard for you
thank you your honor
thank you spotter
[Music]
okay this is this is one of the saddest
cases i've had
on my 20 years on the bench
on the one hand a young man was killed
and on the other
a respected
26-year veteran police officer
made a tragic error by pulling her
handgun instead of her taser
thank you
to everyone who spoke
i am i have been profoundly moved by the
comments of the wright family
dante was very loved
his son has lost a father
and
mr and mrs wright i cannot begin to
understand
the grief of losing a child
i'm so sorry for your loss
kimberly potter honorably served her
community for 26 years
as a police officer
she was a respected officer and
consistently went over and above the
call of duty
she's a wife
a mother an aunt a granddaughter
a colleague and a friend to many
in addition to the letters that were
forwarded to me by mr ing
i received hundreds and hundreds of
letters
in her support
from colleagues family friends
acquaintances
community
leaders and members and even strangers
i read them all
they paint a portrait of a woman who
touched a lot of people
in a good way
i want to talk briefly about the
aggravating factors that were brought up
in this case
as i mentioned before the state
initially took the position
ms potter should receive a sentence
above the guidelines
and file the brief in support of two
aggregate aggravating factors under
blakely
all parties agreed that i would
determine whether aggravating factors
existed to justify a harsher sentence
than that set forth in the guidelines
i feel compelled to address the grounds
for that request
because they were made public and i
think it is important to note they were
not proven in this case
the state did not meet its burden of
proof on the first factor
it is based on defendant causing a
greater than normal danger to the
passenger in the car
and two other officers when she fired
but the shot only hit dante wright
the passenger and the officers were not
injured by that shot
the cases cited by the state in its
brief
did not support its position
in fact they illustrate why why this
case does not involve a greater than
normal danger to others
in the fleming case he fired a gun six
times in a park filled with children
in state versus omaha defendant fired
numerous shots into two apartment
buildings
there is no comparison here
the state also did not meet its burden
of proof on the second bleakly factor
contrary to the state's claims
kimberly potter did not abuse her
position of authority
in fact it is undisputed ms potter or
officer potter was in the line of duty
and doing her job in attempting to
lawfully arrest dante wright on the
warrant
when she mistook her gun for her taser
what's more
she drew her taser legitimately
to protect a fellow officer on the other
side of the vehicle who could have been
dragged and seriously injured if the car
were to speed away
officer potter's conduct clearly was not
significantly more serious
than that typically involved in the
commission of the crime in question
justifying an upward departure
turning to
request for a dispositional departure
there is no question
that ms potter is extremely remorseful
she showed that today she showed that
when
it happened
it is also beyond dispute that she is
particularly amenable to probation
but the court retains the discretion
to make departure decisions
independently
the court is not required to depart even
where mitigating factors are present
and that's set forth in state versus
birch 689 northwest 2nd 276
affirmed by the supreme court
707 northwest 2nd 660.
this has been an extremely difficult
decision
in making my decision i look to the
purposes of incarceration
there are four
retribution
incapacitation
deterrence and rehabilitation
three of the four would not be served in
this case
incapacitation refers to the physical
removal of a convicted person
to prevent them from committing future
crimes
that is not an issue in this case
kimberly potter does not present a
danger of future crimes obviously
deterrence refers to the prevention of
future crime and the idea that those who
have committed crimes
will be discouraged from reoffending
after experiencing punishment
that purpose would not be served here
rehabilitation
is also not a purpose that would justify
incarceration in this case
ms potter does not require
rehabilitation to become a law abiding
citizen
retribution
or serving time as a way for a convicted
person
to pay for the harm inflicted on a
victim
is the sole purpose
that applies in this case
and in this case a young man was killed
because
officer potter was
reckless
there rightfully should be some
accountability
sentencing guidelines are just that
they are guidelines that inform a judge
regarding sentencing
for various crimes
they are not set in stone
the court has the discretion to depart
from guidelines depending on the
particular facts
of a case
a downward durational departure is
justified if a crime is less onerous
than typical
put another way
if the conduct is significantly less
serious
than that typically involved in the
commission
of the crime
sentencing below the
guidelines is justified
i find the facts and circumstances here
justify a downward departure from the
guidelines
first
officer potter's conduct was
significantly less serious
than your typical manslaughter case
the misdemeanor predicate for the
manslaughter count
was reckless handling or use of a
firearm
here everybody agrees and the evidence
is undisputed
that officer potter never intended to
use her firearm
she mistakenly drew her firearm at all
times intending to use her taser
there were police officers and experts
who testified that the use of her taser
was reasonable and appropriate under the
circumstances
circumstances presented for officer
safety reasons
the fact she never intended to draw her
firearm
makes this case less serious than other
cases
second
the scene was chaotic
tense and rapidly evolving
officer potter was required to make a
split second judgment
that constitutes a mitigating
circumstance
finally
unlike other manslaughter one cases
officer potter's actions were not driven
by personal animosity toward dante
wright
instead she was acting in the line of
duty
and effectuating a lawful arrest
this case is highly unusual
the other officer cases tried in this
court
are distinguishable
this is not a cop found guilty of murder
for using his need to pin down a person
for nine and a half minutes
as he gasped for air
this is not a cop found guilty of
manslaughter for intentionally drawing
his firearm
and shooting across his partner and
killing an unarmed woman who approached
approached his squad
this is a cop
who made a tragic mistake
she drew her firearm
thinking it was a taser
and ended up killing a young man
miss potter will you please rise
given all these considerations
and having carefully considered
the comments of the family
of both dante wright
and the comments of kimberly potter as
well as the arguments of counsel
it is the sentence and judgment of this
court
that you shall be committed to the
custody of the commissioner of
corrections
for a period of 24 months
you shall serve two-thirds of that time
or 16 months in prison
and a third unsupervised release
assuming no disciplinary disciplinary
offenses
or conditional release violations
you have credit for 58 days already
served
restitution will be reserved
there'll be a fine of one thousand
dollars and a surcharge of 78 dollars
to be taken out of prison wages
or due within 180 days
you must provide a dna sample
you may not use or possess any firearms
ammunition or explosives
you have the right to appeal the
conviction and sentence
if you are unable to pay the cost of
an appeal
you may apply for leave to appeal at
state expense
by contacting the state public defender
you may be seated miss potter
i'd like to make a few parting comments
i recognize there will be those who
disagree with the sentence
that i granted a significant downward
departure
does not in any way
diminish dante wright's life
his life mattered
and
to those who disagree and feel a longer
prison sentence
is appropriate
as difficult as it may be
please try to empathize with ms potter's
situation
as president barack obama once said
learning to stand in
somebody else's shoes
to see through their eyes
that's how peace begins
and it's up to you to make that happen
empathy is a quality of character
that can change the world
officer
kimberly potter was trying to do the
right thing
of all the jobs in public service
police officers
have the most difficult one
they must make snap decisions
under tense evolving and ever changing
circumstances
they risk their lives every single day
in public service
officer potter made a mistake that ended
tragically
she never intended to hurt anyone
her conduct cries out for a sentence
significantly below the guidelines
okay thank you
thank you
next